von Miller joins us on behalf of Old
Spice see some of the new commercials
this week offering a gifting set of
smell yeah in the back field kits
featuring old spices new invisible spray
antiperspirant sending them to opposing
quarterbacks and running backs these von
Miller the Broncos linebacker are you
really sending some of this to opposing
quarterbacks and running backs to you
know opposing quarterbacks you know
running backs on other teams you know
just you know I like doing so you know I
felt like this would be great to team
the worlds but what quarterback don't
you like I just don't like him at all
like I should have been accorded that so
it's like you know when I'm out down a
football field I feel like we have like
you know this bond I feel like I'm I
feel like I'm a quarterback at heart you
know so like that's like you you know it
makes X's I do and that's why I play the
way our players that I come a themed
like a client you know to be a cool back
you gotta think like over and I feel
like I'm a correlation we just have this
bomb maybe I'm just maybe I was just
going down the road material here
brother
you know I feel like I feel like I'm a
quarterback at heart so I got a bond
with a you know a lot of Quebec's I'm
like are corvex could you play
quarterback in the NFL but like I could
especially you know what coach McCoy you
know no coach show yeah you know coach
leaves any comments on us you know I
feel like yeah I feel like you
definitely we're great quarterbacks
colleges here you know the coop Sunday
series I seen working with the corvex
all the time I feel like you know if I
had those guys coaching the orchestra
I'd be a great player that's willing to
wait well what kind of arm you got are
you gonna be an awesome quarterback are
you going to be gonna throw you're gonna
be like Brady in the pocket I mean you
got to be able to learn to
that wouldn't be much fun I think you
saw the way I you know broken my really
will be you being Krishna uh you know
like I said I'm a quarterback he's a Von
Miller the Broncos linebacker joining us
on behalf of Old Spice
what was the welcome back celebration
like with Brock Osweiler I was dope you
know to have Brock's energy you know
back in the locker room was was amazing
you know I didn't want to leave in the
first place but when he went to Houston
I don't have a great year especially
with with the RJ Hopkins and you know
all the weapons he had over there it
just didn't you know work out for me you
only went to the Browns didn't work out
there so they have it back you know the
Denver Broncos is amazing it feels like
2015 again so we had a lot of great
success that year was wonderful horse
their years or have been a rock as a
movie did you watch any college football
over the weekend the game no we aren't
you glad you didn't stay for the second
half you know I had to come back
remember I have played to say 6:45 we
make smaller so I had even like get out
of it I had a slight it like oh man
that's like 80 edified eight o'clock so
I ran by the hotel you know grab my
stuff and when I got on the plane if I'm
checking the score for the game and I
say we lost we lost and I'm just not
going through you know how Alexis does
UCLA you just had a great day well the
young guys RIT to them anybody have time
to guys you know it just it just happens
like that in fashion for money we've
been able to come back and win before
you know that was just one of the games
that we lost yesterday
do you feel about TJ Ward now playing
for the Buccaneers no but what happene
you know one day it's gonna happen to
you know 95% of us you know the National
Football League that's just that is just
part of it you know when you got a you
know a 20 year old with parks 20-ryo
Justine Simmons you know you got a you
know young Richie come down from I am in
and you know in Carter you know all of
these guys had they had a head break it
up they had great preseason hey dr.
Simmons and whips a great seasons nice
you know once you got those guys coming
in it you know it's uh it makes it hard
for you know guys gonna make decisions
on all players like TJ you know it was
on everyone unfortunate but it's gonna
happen tonight Robert have a pain you
just gotta keep moving I'm um I'm happy
and I'm excited for TJ he would feel
great with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers they
got a pretty good knot in pretty good I
got a excellent defense over there with
with Joe McCoy you know bring drums you
know want Alexander and all these other
pieces that they have on audition I
think he'll be able to you know add
stand there's gonna be great
what do you do better than Jay Jay I
want everything on defense so I mean you
know JJ he's great
you know ready boys I mean he's great
against ranked because he's not only
gradually taper indeed mrs. lead at
rushing the passer
he's a minute and um you know his effort
on the football field he's you know
usually that bad down Bosworth you know
I do you know everything from silo silo
you know coverage and run defense
rushing the passer you know whatever it
whatever is asking me they do go on the
defensive bonus that's what I'm gonna do
well my best friends you know you can't
you can't you can't you know get my
negative comment you know Neal about JJ
water you know I'm like you know and
then I'm like KJ waters at home I got a
jersey in my locker my locker I got a
jersey in my basement right now and I'm
jay-z and it's like in the time position
in the man cave move you just wrote hero
dumb we swap jerseys and he wrote like
this
not on my on my Jersey and it talks
about you know going to Afghanistan we
went to Afghanistan together for the USO
tour and some of the stuff that we did
so you know JJ's one of my favorite
players on and off football yeah so you
can't get come coming about from being
about JJ's I love today how many
quarterback jerseys do you have in your
man cave I got a couple I got a I got a
Andy Dalton I got a antenna he's oh yeah
I paid many of course there's drew Brees
I got Philip Rivers you know thanks oh
yeah and I got a camp Boone Jerry Jerry
this was this was I really know this is
before like Super Bowl 50 I got from my
second in the league the since you're
joining us behalf of Old Spice you can
tell me the smelliest player in the
league is who he's great he's great but
one time we played them last year I
think it was a we played it we went to
Oakland lost somehow he ended up on top
of me so this that's never good at all
but Gabe Jackson yeah Jackson Eddie
that is him wait he ended up on top of
me last year when we played in Oakland
which is which is not good at all well
we just gave him a nickname it's Gabe
funky Jackson Von Miller more you can
see his commercials Old Spice and smell
you in the backfield kits and he's ready
to send those out to the opposing
quarterbacks running backs and the
offensive line of the Oakland Raiders
Vaughn always great to talk to you good
luck in the upcoming season all right
guys I appreciate you all right that's
von Miller the Dan Patrick show we
on audience